now the white knight is just relocating
itself it's going to remove that black
defender the blockader the black rook
from in front of that white pawn and
actually that white point is going to
cross black history it's just going to
the knight is going to jump to the a7
square or the b6 square and
and no way to defend now erroneous
fortress is being hammered down is being
broken dismantled white tonight is going
for that black rook and if the black
bishop moves as well why does rook can
attack it plenty of
plenty of ways to win this one also
remember magnus only needs to draw why
does he seem so well no i think this is
just relief
i mean i mean he i think he's you can
see it there the fist pump ah it's over
you guys magnus carlsen is ready for
another final in the meltwater champions
chess drawer knocking out live on
aronian in the semi-finals here
and uh
yeah is that relief david yup relief
because he knows it's been a really
difficult day levono has not given all
right and that means he is in another
final magnus carlsen and that was his
reaction when
levon aronian eventually resigned in
this game another win for minus carlsen
two wins today
to win the semi-final against there you
go
against livon aronian